if enduring the worst weather that  Mother Nature can throw at them wasn't  enough the residents on this streets are  now faced with another problem a very  aggressive and angry six foot long  problem however head out of the city and  things are far worse roads and bridges  have been destroyed and landslides have  killed dozens and left many more  unaccounted for  tens of thousands of residents have been  left without electricity and without  water and stores have been emptied as  people loot and steal what they can for  they know that whilst it appears calm at  the moment the weather that caused this  devastation could well be coming back  the tropical storm Manuel which hit the  Pacific coast earlier this week is now  out over the ocean strengthening and  changing to become a hurricane a  hurricane which forecasters say will  soon be heading for land once again so  whilst this beast might now be under  control it's clear the weather is not  James Banks Sky News